[Musik]
wladimir putin ist nicht irgendein club
er wäre die perfekte figur für einen
spionage film und die geschichte die wir
euch in diesem video vorstellen werden
leider schon sehr stark an einem
klassischen agenten zähler
denn heute werden darüber einen
schlüssel konflikt zwischen russland
deutschland und die vereinigten staaten
sprechen über ein milliardenschweres
megaprojekt und eine person welche die
gesamte energiepolitik eines so
wichtigen landes geht deutschland
ruinieren kann
alexei navalny das hat sie bereit da
lasst uns sofort loslegen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele stellen sich die frage wie viel
macht hat russland wirklich immerhin
sprechen wir über eines der größten
länder der welt dessen
bruttoinlandsprodukt aber kleiner ist
als das italiens warum hat russland also
überhaupt soviel gericht nun einer der
gründe dafür ist erdgas sieht euch mal
folgende vater dieser karte könnte er
mit leichtigkeit erkennen auf welche
weise halb europa von russischem gas
abhängig ist die staatsmittel europa hat
sich daran gewöhnt was seinen kompletten
gasbedarf beim östlichen nachbarn zu
decken es ist ja so nah und bild auch
deutschland ist da natürlich vorne mit
dabei und zu 60 prozent von russischem
gas abhängig seit jahren sucht die
europäische union nach alternativen
doch wenn man ganz nüchtern die fakten
betrachtet ist der trend klar
deutschland für sich noch stärker von
russland abhängig machen
fortschritt parat im juni 2021 den
ersten seiner beiden zwei stellen wir
stellen vor
nord stream 2 eine gaspipeline die
russland direkt mit deutschland
verbindet mit dieser gigantischen zeit
lang wird deutschland die versorgung mit
russischem gas problemlos gewährleisten
können das projekt ist mit 115
milliarden euro schwer und essen findet
sich kurz vor seiner fertigstellung
eines darf man aber bei all den jubel
nicht vergessen
daneben wäre auch vorbei wird
deutschland also wirklich in der lage
sein austrias 2 fertig zu stellen
aufgepasst denn dieses projekt ist der
auslöser eines gläubigen und ernsten
konflikt eines konflikts zwischen
deutschland und den usa
außerdem könnte dieses milliardenprojekt
ausgerechnet wegen eines herrn den bach
runtergehen alexej nawalny ist der
bekannteste putin-kritiker russlands
dieser mann stellt eine echte bedrohung
für putin da eine so große dass er im
sommer 2020 einen giftanschlag zum opfer
die wir haben über die tradition des
gifts in der russischen politik ja sogar
ein eigenständiges video beträgt aber
natürlich ist nach val die nicht der
hauptverantwortliche der probleme ganz
im gegenteil
offensichtlich wirklich das missglückte
attentat auf ein us atom
wie viel macht hat also navalny warum
hat deutschland ein so starkes interesse
daran gas von russland zu kaufen und
baumwolle den usa in austin zwei
unbedingt stoppen heute werden diese
fragen natürlich beantworten aber zuerst
wollen wir uns ein wenig mit der
geschichte dahinter befassen
[Musik]
die schattenseite des atomausstiegs
wenn es ein anti atomkraft land par
excellence gibt das ist sicherlich
deutschland schließlich sind bündnis 90
die grünen eine der wichtigsten parteien
im land und die grünen wurden 1980 im
schönen karlsruhe genau deswegen
gegründet um den totalen atomausstieg
durchzusetzen
[Musik]
ja und nur einen tag später kann man
sagen dass dies auf voller linie
gelungen innerhalb nur weniger jahre hat
doch schon fast alle reaktoren
abgeschaltet
zur veranschaulichung im jahr 2002
betrug der anteil der kernenergie am
energiemix deutschlands 19 prozent im
jahr 2021 liegt sie bei drei prozent und
der plan ist so schnell wie möglich auf
null zu kommen
deutschland ist aber auch der größte
energieverbraucher in europa es muss
also im zuge des ausstiegs aus der
kernenergie mehr energie aus anderen
quellen erzeugen
nun schauen wir uns mal diese grafik in
deutschland gibt es also immer mehr
grüne energie
aber es ist immer noch nicht möglich
sich zu 100 prozent auf sie verlassen
die speicherung von energie ist sehr
teuer und ein windrad oder israel
produziert nur dann energie wenn der
wind bläst oder die sonne scheint und
welche alternativen gibt es die
einfachste wäre kohle aber sie ist auch
die umwelt schädigt und was ist ein tick
besser genau man könnte sagen dass
erdgas die am wenigsten umwelt lassen
energiequelle innerhalb der
umweltbelastenden lässt um euch eine
vorstellung zu geben
bei kohle werden für jede erzeugte
kilowattstunde strom 820 tonnen
treibhausgase in die atmosphäre
ausgestoßen
bei erdöl etwa 720 tonnen gas hingegen
liegt bei 420 tonnen gegenüber kohle
also knapp die hälfte mit anderen worten
in zeiten der energiewende ist erdgas
das neue erdöl und deutschland ist der
beste beweis dafür
[Musik]
während die frisch wiedervereinigten
bundesrepublik im jahr 1990 noch 40
terawattstunden strom aus gas erzeugt
hat waren es 2020 bereits mehr als 94
terawattstunden mehr als doppelt so viel
also es stimmt zwar dass gas relativ
gesehen einen geringeren anteil am mix
aus macht vergessen sie aber nicht dass
der energiebedarf in deutschland von
jahr zu jahr steigt eine vorstellung zu
geben
deutschland verbraucht heute 90
milliarden kubikmeter gas pro jahr und
bis 2030 soll diese zahl auf 110
milliarden kubikmeter ansteigen
das gas hunger steigt also unaufhörlich
aber wohin so viel gas nehmen und nicht
stehlen schauen uns das doch gleich mal
an
liebesgrüße aus moskau erdgas wird auf
zwei verschiedene arten transportiert da
packt kleinen durch das leitungen oder
tatonka als flüssigerdgas lng genannt im
zweiten fall wird das gas verflüssigt
und können dann ganz bequem zum
zielhafen geschippert werden
dort wird das lng in einer anlage wieder
in einen kasten gewandelt das durch
pipelines an den ort des tatsächlichen
verbrauchs gepunktet das problem bei
dieser technologie ist das sehr recht
teuer ausfällt und mindestens eine
anlage zur ratifizierung benötigt so und
jetzt preis vergibt ist diese anlagen
auch in deutschland nun im moment nicht
es gibt es auch pläne sollte zu bauen
aber bis dahin kommt alles gas durch
pipelines und 60 prozent dieses gases
kommt eben aus russland aber aufgepasst
in deutschland ist ja nicht das einzige
land das gas vom westlichen riesen kauft
wie ihr seht sind länder wie finnland
oder rumänien zu 100 prozent von
russischem gas abhängig und ich weiß
dass viele von euch jetzt vielleicht
denken wo ist das problem
diese große vogel kapitalistisch weine
von visual politik wollen doch nur
wieder gegen putin hätten viele kaufen
ihr gas und öl doch von ländern die noch
viel viel autoritär regiert werden okay
in diesem punkt muss ich euch
uneingeschränkt recht geben putin ist
bei weitem nicht der größte aller touren
die natürliche rohstoffe an den rest der
welt verkaufen
aber wir müssen auch eines erkennen
putin ist bereit sein gas als politische
waffe einzusetzen
außerdem wäre es das erste mal dass er
das wird nicht tun 2006 drehte erlegen
eines politischen machtspiel ist die
gashähne zur ukraine zu drei jahre
später tat er es wieder
und damals betraf der lieferstopp auch
deutschland wieso das verrät diese katze
auf dieser karte sehen sie die pipelines
durch welche das wird deutschland
bestimmte russische gas geleitet wird
bis 2011 gab es keine alternativen zum
transit durch die ukraine oder
weißrussland mit anderen worten wenn man
das gas aus ging wurde es auch für die
deutsche das war also die pragmatische
lösung ganz einfach eine gas pipeline
bauen die russland direkt mit
deutschland verwendet eine pipeline
durch die ostsee nun das war das projekt
nord stream 1 das 2012 abgeschlossen
wurde
aber deutschland braucht doch mehr gas
und es will sich nicht mehr auf die
ukrainischen pipelines verlassen müssen
und so kam es dass von den produzenten
von 110 1 schnell ein secret angekündigt
wurde
titel nord stream 2 die rache des
schröder und ich weiß was viele von euch
denken wo ist das problem
schließlich ändert sich nicht viel ob
man es toll findet oder nicht russland
verkauft sein da schon lang nach europa
das tat ist schon voraus und forsten 230
unterschied war über welche länder das
gas geleitet wurde und wir ein punkt in
dem nicht zustimmen muss denn es gibt
ein klares auf sein dieser geschichte
die ukraine denkt mal darüber nach wenn
russland als ein gas direkt nach
deutschland schicken kann können sie die
versorgung der keine ohne mit der wimper
zu zucken unterbrechen
von einem tag auf den anderen wäre die
ukraine der gnade russland ausgeliefert
und das erklärt natürlich warum die
ersten länder die allein schlugen die
postkommunistischen staaten wagen denn
sie wissen aus der eigenen geschichte
noch ganz genau wie kalt sich russische
imperialismus anfühlt
sieben eu-länder lehnen nord stream ab
zu diesen sieben ländern gehört polen
tschechien das baltikum und generell
alle länder die früher von der
sowjetunion besetzt waren mit ausnahme
ostdeutschlands natürlich stichwort aus
deutschland kommt dann nicht auch angela
merkel her wohl scheinbar hat er die
sowjetbesatzung etwas anders in
erinnerung als unsere nachbarn denn
alles was ich zu sagen hatte waren etwa
schaut nur wie ich zittere die post
kommunistischen länder wollen wiederum
geht nach hause und lassen mich in ruhe
und so begann 2015 das russische
unternehmen gazprom mit dem bau der
pipeline
plötzlich fühlte sich die ostsee wieder
mit spezialschiffen zum bau von
pipelines
immerhin haben sie es hier mit einem der
faszinierendsten projekte der
ingenieurskunst überhaupt zu tun
ein projekt das bereits mehr als 9,5
milliarden euro gekostet hat ist also
noch aus dass niemand in der lage wäre
es noch aufzuhalten aber dann trat der
nächste akteur unserer geschichte auf
den plan und auf die bremse
druck aus den usa die vereinigten
staaten und deutschland
warum schreibt immer starke verbündete
und das liegt nicht nur daran dass sie
beide teil der natur sind während
frankreich den usa an vielen fronten den
rücken gekehrt hatte wie zum beispiel im
irak krieg ist deutschland
außenpolitisch fast immer hat uns mit
den vereinigten staaten gegangen und
genau deshalb kam diese nachricht ja so
überraschend nord stream zweitrangig
sanktionen gegen russische gaspipeline
ja und ich weiß was einige denken werden
das alles waren doch nur wieder die
chance herum gepolter nichts als heiße
luft die sofort wieder entweicht wenn er
nicht mehr präsident ist nun nichts
dergleichen in der tat wurden diese
sanktion im kongress sowohl von
demokraten als auch republikaner
verabschiedet denn es gibt viele gründe
warum die vereinigten staaten den bau
dieser pipeline um jeden preis
verhindern wollen der erste ist rein
geopolitisch es ist in ihrem interesse
die ukraine zu schützen
die als verbündete der usa ist und die
sind nicht daran interessiert dass
russland noch mehr macht bekommt der
zweite ist wirtschaftlicher natur
die usa wollen ihr flüssig erdgas in
europa verkaufen und das erklärt auch
schon die ersten sanktionen einigen
unternehmen ausreichten um sicht von
astrium zwei zu distanzieren
[Musik]
bereits im jahr 2000 die scheiße auf
shop hat kleine baufirma aus sie ist
ihre beteiligung an austrian zeit
aufgegeben
demonstrationen zu vermeiden allerdings
wurde vorerst kein unternehmen wirklich
wirtschaftlich bestraft es stimmt dass
die usa die möglichkeit der verhängung
von wirtschaftssanktionen gegen alle an
diesem projekt beteiligten unternehmen
geprüft haben lange mussten sie jedoch
keinen gebrauch davon machen
doch im sommer 2020 änderte sich das
alles
französische und schwedische labors
bestätigen dass navalny mit snow
wittstock vergiftet wurde nochmals
alexej nawalny ist der vielleicht größte
politische feind wladimir putin der
wirtschaft ist ein sehr starkes gift das
hauptsächlich von russische spionin
verwendet wird alles deutet darauf hin
dass dieser mann und putin nahe
stehenden personen vergiftet worden ist
und obwohl der wahl die überlebt hat und
in einem deutschen krankenhaus behandelt
wurde ändert diese nachricht eben alles
plötzlich ist frankreich das keine klare
position aus kriegen zwei hatte den
glück der länder beigetreten die dagegen
sind vorher war es eine frage der reinen
bio politik nun ist ist eine frage der
ethik man könnte es als eine art
bestrafung okay es wurde versucht gegen
seine politischen gegen dazu kommen und
so wie die ermordung von karubi viele
von bensheims großen projekten ist auch
ihr arabisches und scheitern gebracht
hat könnte die versucht ermordung von
navalny das große projekt von wladimir
putin zu scheitern droht eine
vorstellung zu geben eine von troms
letzten maßnahmen bevor alles weiß
auswahl ist war neue
wirtschaftssanktionen um nostalgie zwei
zu stoppen zum zeitpunkt der erstellung
dieses videos haben sich mehr als 18
unternehmen entschieden das projekt zu
verlassen und die große frage die sich
nun einstellen ist das wird joe biden
beiden ist prinzipiell gegen die
pipeline an das will er sich aber auch
nicht mit deutschland anlegen
mehrfach hat er betont die von schon
zuhause transatlantische beziehungen
wieder ins rollen wie lautet also seine
höchst nun eher wer sich unbedingt
waschen dabei aber irgendwie nicht
wirklich nass werden bei ihm das
gelingen usa sanktionieren russisches
schiff beim bau der nord-stream-pipeline
in der ostsee beiden behielt
konstellation also aufrecht zunächst
aber nur für russische zusammen
das betreffe in der ersten schicht kies
fortuna und ist alles dieser
konstruktion schiffe von denen ich euch
vorhin erzählt habe ein schiff mit
riesigen kränen um fette pipelines auf
hoher see zu verlegen nun sowohl dieses
schiff als auch alle anderen die ihn
beim bau der tat hessen werden unter
us-sanktionen fall tja und was meint ihr
haben diese maßnahmen ausreichend
gewicht tun das projekt noch zu stoppen
nun alles deutet darauf hin dass sie es
nicht haben
tatsächlich nahm das schiff nur ein paar
tage nach bekanntgabe der sanktionen
sollen arbeit wieder auf als wäre nichts
geschehen
[Musik]
zurzeit punkte erstellung des videos
insgesamt 1230 km nur noch 148 bis zur
fertigstellung mit anderen worten es
scheint fast unmöglich dass diese
zaghaften sanktionen das projekt killen
werden und das bei beiden ist auch er
kennt sein außenminister in tony blinken
hat nun alle am bau dennoch zum 2pac
beteiligten unternehmen gewandt die
arbeiten sofort einzustellen beiden
erwägt ernsthaft neue härtere sanktionen
und vielleicht hat das auch mit
folgenden support kroos verschiebt
beiden nominierung von burns als
direktor wegen nord stream pipeline
nun ich habe euch eine
spionagegeschichte versprochen und hielt
cruise und andere republikanische
senatoren erhöhten nehme ich noch einmal
gewaltig den druck auf beiden sie machen
die ernennung des neuen direktors von
härteren sanktionen gegen die austria 2
aber welche sanktionen genau haben sie
eigentlich nun die einzigen sanktionen
die jetzt in letzter minute noch
irgendwie wirkung zeigen könnten müssten
vor allem gegen deutsche firmen
gerichtet sein
vergesst nicht dass die pipeline wenn
alles nach plan läuft bis zum sommer
dieses jahres fertig sein wird
mit anderen worten wenn sie wirklich
noch stoppen wollen müssen sie
drastische maßnahmen ergreifen
sanktionen gegen einen ihrer wichtigsten
verbündeten und zwar zeichen deswegen
macht der sprecher der amerikanischen
botschaft in berlin deutlich dass die
usa entschlossen sind alle verfügbaren
hebel in bewegung zu setzen um die
fertigstellung von nord stream 2 zu
verhindern und diese klare ansage war
direkt an die deutsche bundesregierung
gerichtet
was also auf den ersten blick als recht
und bedeutende geschichte erscheinen mag
entpuppt sich plötzlich als eines der
großen dilemmas in den europa zurzeit
steckt einerseits erwerben sich sowohl
deutschland als auch die gesamte
regierung seit jahrzehnten an günstigen
erdgas nord stream zwei würde der
europäischen industrie helfen
wettbewerbsfähiger zu werden
andererseits würde es aber auch ein
betrug die ukraine darstellt ein land
mit 44 millionen einwohner das sich seit
jahren in einer schrecklichen krise
befindet welche durch russland kräftig
befeuert wird ganz nach dem motto lieber
das einstige bruder volk ins elend
stürzen als es dem fenster lassen daher
lauten die fragen an euch haltet ihr
noch zwei eigentlich für eine gute idee
glaubt ihr dass die partner in frage
gestellt oder können die usa sie
vielleicht doch noch stoppen
wie immer sind wir auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass auch
dieses video gefallen hat was ihr habt
es könnte ein leck hat es mit euren
freunden und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal zu abonnieren
machs gut und ist
[Musik]